and finally new role Donald Trump must
be inducted into the Friars Club because
he's a comedian I say that not as a
cheap insult but because he works like a
comedian I do stand-up dates he does
rallies I feed off the crowd
he feeds off the crowd when I find a bit
a hunk a chunk that the audience really
digs I keep doing it and so does this
chunk since last April one of trumps
go-to killer bits involves me although
I'm only referred to by a variety of
colorful names like crazy maniac wacko
comedian lowlife dummy and yet he often
refers to this program as a big show
they have this wacky guy on television
and he was doing an interview dick show
one of these crazy maniacs on the show
big show
[Laughter]
so tonight out of respect for the
president am I officially changing our
name from Real Time with Bill Maher to
Big Show with crazy mania and what is it
that crazy maniac has been saying that
puts such a bug up Trump's ass I'll let
him tell you I mean you have one guy in
television I'm telling you he's not
believing there's no way we're ever
gonna get him out of office
he's not leaving you know that and then
he's staying long I'm telling you he's
not leaving he'll never leave he's gonna
stay that's it he tells the story about
how I keep saying that if he loses the
election in November he's not going to
leave and I'll tell you why I keep
saying that because if Trump loses the
election in November he's not going to
leave now maybe I will be shown to be a
crazy maniac but I'm not alone in this
anymore
last year Michael Cohen agreed given my
experience working for mr. Trump and I
fear that if he loses the election in
2020 that there will never be a peaceful
transition of power say do me a favor
try and picture Donald Trump losing an
election graciously go ahead I'll wait
try to imagine him on election night
saying it was an honor to serve but the
people have spoken and I respect the
results
I've called president-elect Chlo Bashar
to tell her and
[Applause]
- tell her I'm rooting for her to
succeed it's inconceivable because above
all Donald Trump wants you to know one
thing about him he doesn't lose period
other than two marriages three casinos
and airline a football league four
magazines of vodka brand a university in
a charity Donald Trump never loses
anything
and never long so why would the White
House be different this is a guy who
farts and blames it on the dog and he
doesn't have a dog they once asked Trump
the difference between him and Richard
Nixon I don't leave there's a big
difference that'll leave Perry is last
week last week what's on his desk
one thing a map of the 2016 election he
still hasn't gotten over the election he
won he's a sore winner so imagine when
he actually loses here's what he said in
2016 when he thought he was going to
lose this whole election is being rigged
the whole thing is one big fix so the
groundwork has been set
if Trump loses there's zero chance he
doesn't say it's a conspiracy by the
deep state trying to take another
rightful election from you people my
people yes let's talk about his people
the ones who would rather burn the place
to the ground than hand the country over
to some pinko was trying to give them
health care because his people have a
very different idea about how power is
transferred in a democracy he's not
gonna be removed my 357 Magnum isn't
comfortable with that yeah the truck nut
demographic
is not going to take it well and Trump
is counting on that he once said I have
the support of the police the military
the bikers
I am the tough people but they don't
play a tough until they they meaning the
Democrats go to a certain point and then
it would be very very bad go to a
certain point and what could that point
be where we need to involve the bikers
and the other tough people like maybe
you losing an election is that when
we've pushed it too far so my question
to all Democratic candidates is what's
the plan if you win and the next day he
claims he's voiding the election because
of irregularities he's hearing about
what do you do what do you do when the
crowd that was in Virginia this week
22,000 strong marches on Washington mrs.
scary moment and when I've asked
Democrats what do we do if he doesn't go
there answer is always some variation of
we have to win big win big not just win
vote amount of office by 25 percentage
points it's more than squeaking out a
narrow victory we have to defeat him
decisively we would need a landslide
okay first of all no no we don't have to
win by a landslide Jesus
[ __ ] Democrats I am so sick of
Democrats volunteering to play by two
different sets of rules that's the new
paradigm Republicans can win by one vote
but we're not legitimate unless it's a
landslide [ __ ] and - do you really think
it wouldn't matter if it was that they
would suddenly get rational about math
and facts
they believed Hillary read a pedophile
ring out of a pizza parlor do you think
that the same Senate that refuses to
even hear witnesses during an
impeachment trial is gonna stop Trump
when he calls the enact next election
rigged who's going to stand up to him
the Attorney General who auditioned for
the job the Senate Majority Leader who
killed every bill that could keep the
Russians from interfering the Supreme
Court justices he appointed who oh
that's right Susan Collins she always
comes through
you